It's the medium is the message and it
doesn't matter what we say on TV.
Why are we all here tonight?
Why am I asking this question?
There's a huge technology involved in TV
which surrounds you physically handle
the effect of that huge service
environment on you personally is vast.
The effect of the program is incidental.
Marshall Mcluhan's famous saying,
the medium is the message poses
interesting questions for the age of
online video.
He gets to the basic point in that clip.
New Forms of media actually reorganize
our consciousness in McLuhan's time.
The great shift in media was from print
to electronic media,
radio and more importantly,
television,
where the printed book was what he
called hot media and intense.
One way offloading of high definition
information into your mind.
The TV was cool.
It was low definition on in a busy
house,
interrupted by commercials playing to
all the senses.
In other words,
it demanded your participation to fill
in the gaps,
every kind of media from print to radio
to music,
to television,
to the internet,
creates a kind of invisible environment
around us.
When you're watching TV,
you may be aware of the particular show
of how funny or engaging it is of how
relatable the characters are,
but rarely do we perceive or step back
to understand what it actually means to
watch tv,
what it means to be in that audio visual
and immersive sensory environment.
It's no surprise that the great triumph
of television is the triumph of
advertising,
but what could possibly be more attuned
to the medium of television than
commercials in 30 seconds or a minute
they invite or require participation
triggering each and every one of the
senses.
This is not to say that advertisements
are good for us,
just good for TV.
Just as early television took its cues
from print,
radio,
and film before coming into it's own
online.
Video has taken its cues from tv,
but like TV online video is a wholly new
medium,
operating in its own environment.
Reshaping our consciousness.
Again,
I mean just the way we watch is
different.
We're close up to the screens with the
screens are small,
often the size of a phone,
whereas my hand is rarely on the remote
control.
It's nearly always on the mouse,
inviting different kinds of agencies
like the ease at which you can scan
through something.
All these things,
and I'm sure many more that you could
identify have effects on the styles that
become widely viewed and adopted,
but I think the largest ingredient of
online video is the awareness that every
consumer is a potential creator.
The appeal of low five,
of making something that anyone could
potentially produce is extremely
important to the culture of online
video.
So much so I'm tempted to say that
what's considered flawed and imperfect
videography in the eyes of other media
is actually essential to online.
Video Mcluhan was fond of saying that
radio was more suited to packages to
completed products.
While TV had a preoccupation with
processes to seeing how things were
done,
and I think this extends even further
with online video.
Just take a look at daily Vlogs,
perhaps the form that's most tailored to
the medium of online video,
the process of filming your day of how
the camera moves is vital to the concept
and there are certainly a number of
other styles that have been proven to be
highly compatible with online video.
One that comes to mind is animated
explainer.
Let's try to make a list of some more in
the comments below.
I don't completely agree with Mcluhan
when he says the effect of the program
is incidental,
but I do think that great valuable
content for online video has to be
matched with a style that fits the
medium.
Of course,
it's still really early in the history
of this medium in 10 or 20 years with a
better perspective.
We'll be able to look back at all this
work and point to the first true
masterpieces of the medium,
but what's exciting now is that those of
us who are working in online video are
in effect creating the form.
We're writing the language of this new
medium and for that reason,
experimentation and innovation have to
continue to be a top priority and even
for those who just watch,
it's essential to study this medium as
it grows,
to be aware of its message and the
unique environment it creates because
all aspects of the media,
I have an irresistible force when in
design.
Hey guys,
some exciting news.
I have 20 more nerd writer mugs
available on my patrion page.
Learned a lot from the first batch,
but God they came out so great.
So there are $5 and in order to make the
price work,
you'll get them after five videos and
I'll be watching that.
So I do a video a week now so it should,
shouldn't be too long.
Um,
I basically break even.
I just want you guys to have them
because I think they're so cool.
Click here anywhere on the mug and you
can claim them while they last.
The first batch went pretty fast.
Thanks again for watching.
And new video will be out next
Wednesday.
And I'll be in comments to talk about
this because I want to talk about this a
lot more.
So find me down there and see you next
time.